[موسيقى]
الله يا شبكه غير الرسميه ومجموعه من
الجنرالات والمتقاعدين من الحرس الثوري
وكل واحد منهم مسؤول عن الجانب من
امبراطوريه الحرس التوريد بعضها هؤلاء
الجنرالات انخرطوا في اداره الاعمال
الاقتصاديه واخرون
ايه خامه الاسئله
التجسس ونشاطات سياسيه وهذه المجموعه
صغيره نسبيا بين 20 الى 30 شخصا وهم الذين
يتخذون القرارات المعقده جدا نيابه عن
الحرس الثوري بنسبه الوضع الحالي يعتقدون
بين السيد
يجب ان يبقى هو في قمه هذا الهرم وربما
يقبلون بان ان النظامين
حتى يجب ان تستمر بعد خامنئي ولكنها
سيفعلون ان يكون هنالك خليفه
السيد الخامنئي الذي شخص يمكن يسيطر عليه
بخلاف خامنئي وهو خاض بها لحرس الثوري
[موسيقى]
في ايران فالحرسه
هو قوه الشرطيه وهو ايضا عسكريه تحمي
النزاهه اراضي
فيه اشكالات كثيره فهذا الدعم لا ياتي
بثمن
مره يتدخل فيها حرسه
النظام ضد الخصومه السياسيين المحليين
فالحارس حتى اوريكانيه يجب ان يتلقى شيئا
بالمقابل او مكافحه
كانت في النفوذ السياسي
على اتخاذ القرارات الاستراتيجيه وهذا
التطور وبشكل تدريجي
طبعا اولها من في اخرى عطيه النظام يقودها
لا علم الشيعه الى دكتاتوريه عسكريه
والحرس الثوري لا يحمي فقط النظام ضد
الاعداد الداخلي والخارجين بل ينخرطوا
بشكل متزايد في اداره شؤون الدوله
[موسيقى]